こーにゃんカードは僕が今まで集めた遊戯用のノーマルカードあんまり使わないカード
全種類ですとりあえず名前で数えてみましょう
予想当てましょう6の予想は1万5000個の例である
の島に山1-1番215,000
[音楽]
pr
はぁっ
ヒルってくれよません
果てしない
car を
7800もいいですよ寝ちまうは絶対ありますねこれ
一部をイケメン
[音楽]
ん
開いて泳げば異変を渡しました全部感が終わりました
今僕が持っている遊戯王カーブのノーマルカードの数は
[音楽]
11801まいしねえ飯
1束100万円のところガーッと並べた時118たがあったのでここには今
1万1800ない友情カードがありますよえっ
[拍手]
8割からくらい国だろ&僕はこんなことをしたかと言いますと安保かーっ
結をやってきてこれないカードなるという4カードと心が通じ合ってる機体だけに期待
カード金と勝てない
こちらですわかりますねこの関税これめちゃ曲ねあなブルーアイズなんですよこれ
ホログラフィックでやっててすごいベアなカードなんですけどこのホログラフィック
レアのブルーアイズ僕の魂
のカードです今すごい広い部屋に入って一番舞園遊行カーブはばら撒けるような空間に
結んで今からこの一番マネージャーの有力かと全部裏返してばらまいてその中にこれも
潜ませて広い人に潜ませてもらった分ライズ僕は僕今度隠されたプレート nerf で
見つけられるかちょっと挑戦しようと思いますが僕ぐらいの12時になるとカーズと魂
も繋がってるってもた後すぐ見つける
飲んでちょっと実際にやってみようと思いますありますかよね
iq でまず11,800円の優良カードをこのフィールド上に全部裏側守備表示では
ない
全部裏側でセットしていきますが以後
[音楽]
ああああああ
この変化には11,800万円いうカード裏趣味裏側で置いてありますここからが本番
やから宏さんがこれの伝説のフォロアーティックブルーアイズを国土で泊しますこれ
グラフィッグリス俺はハーフんで見つけることができるのか
これくらいの中一緒になると関西で執筆から徒歩2分3つ
業界外入れるんだよ会社その間に隠してくださいはーい
はいっ
by な袋デュア密集しすぎているたら狙ってくると
[音楽]
どうでしょこれ
ボイスか動いてねいつまた家で800分の1ですよねっ
いきます8位
佐渡
言えないでしょ
ここらへんだと思う
あってっどこら辺だろうゼッ通常起動
ん
ここらへんずないん
感じてもらってソウルそうで走路金城位
press conference とめくってみましょう助かった
[音楽]
ここじゃないがかかってまだ一回もドアですよね
お皿ないで
第9地区シンプルっていうところにんじゃりますよああああ
よね
出したりそういう感じで狙いつけていけないぞ
[音楽]
ああああああ
大ここへジョブ
絶対かもれない
無職だ
[音楽]
バコーンありがとうございません
厚真大花
えええまあねこれ本当にあったんですけどっ
あ
で必要だぜ
いやーでもこれ見つけたら
入らない
40見つける俺の相棒
20分経過もうにスプーン
うわーん
[音楽]
ban ban
ずっと行けかもう
欲しかった時があった美味しかった時カッターん
すみません
こっちの以降めくり進んでほしかったという場面があったねううーー do
[音楽]
dj
ashandan
ていました
ん
本所
者
[音楽]
[拍手]
いやー
いやーです早くないですか8西ビガー
山中4分52秒
いやいや増的でしょ早いですよね
よしかなり余ってる守ってますよ
ヤッター
1回も声かけそいやっ